[inaudible]
deep beneath the earth's surface.
There's a scorching ball
of iron surrounded by an
ocean of boiling hot liquid
metal,
the earth's core.
It's as toasty as the surface of the
sun with enough heat to brew more than a
trillion cups of coffee per hour.
That's over a hundred coffees for
every single person on the planet.
What if the sizzling cores
suddenly cooled down?
Could our planet still function with
a frozen core or would we just become
another lifeless rock orbiting the sun?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if
the earth's core cooled down.
Ever since it was formed, the inner
core of the earth has been losing heat,
but it's still blazing hot
around 6,000 degrees. Of course,
no one has ever been to
the center of the earth.
The unbearable heat is one of the reasons
you don't want to get any closer to it.
If only a cool down a bit,
maybe we could go and see what's inside
our planet and if all our guests is
about the earth,
we're right.
There are many things on
earth to make life possible.
Our geomagnetic field is one of them.
It protects us from all kinds of space.
Radiation, including highly
charged particles, constantly
blasting from the sun.
The magnetic field acts as a shield and
to flex them around our planet. That way,
no solar winds can strip
away our atmosphere,
which is also an essential element for
life here on earth. And guess what?
This magnetic field is
generated by the earth's core.
As the planet spins the
two parts of the core,
the inner solid core and the outer
liquid one move at different speeds
generating electric currents. Those
currents generate our geomagnetic field.
If the earth's core cooled down,
it wouldn't produce any currents.
The Earth would lose its
magnetic field if that happens,
be ready for all kinds of bad things
because no magnetic field means no
atmosphere and no atmosphere.
Well in short,
the earth would start looking
a little more like Mars.
No breathing exercise could calm you
down since you wouldn't even be able to
breathe without a pressure
suit and an oxygen mask.
Since the frozen core wouldn't
heat up rocks, water, gas,
and other geological material anymore,
the earth itself would be getting
colder and colder. On the other hand,
volcanoes would no longer be spewing lava.
Continence would stop drifting away
from each other and earthquakes would
completely disappear. Nobody could
survive on that earth for too long,
but it would be a good simulation
of life on Mars. Who knows?
Maybe we'd have enough
time to pack up our stuff,
jump on a space ship and get off of this
planet before it became absolutely dead.
But if someone very curious,
decided to stay on earth and to
finally drill a hole into the core,
try to convince them not to the
core may have lost all a team,
but the pressure there and would still
be 3.5 million times higher than it is on
earth surface.
Anyone bold enough to go down there
would be squeezed into the core.
Becoming one with the earth literally
looks like the plan is core would be
better off if it remained as blisteringly
hot as it is and maybe drilling
through the earth isn't the best idea
either. But that's a question for another.
What if.